i would never cut my onions or do
uncooked onions who puts uncooked onions
on something excellent well you could
put on cookies
as you know i have some serious culinary
skills
so today i'm hosting my own food
competition
where i prepare some really awesome
meals for my friends
to see if they can decide did i cook the
food or did the supermarket prepare the
food winner gets a huge prize and let's
thank vitamix for sponsoring this video
i'm going to throw on my trusty dirty
un-iron apron here this is an apron of
experience folks if you walk into a
hospital and you see a young doctor with
a really clean white coat
that means they're rookies anyway i'm
going to be preparing
all of my meals with my trusty vitamix
a3500
12 cup food processor attachment oh yeah
thanks bear with self detect
let's make some granola bars mixed nuts
12 cup food processor what the
multi-use blade this is the multi-use
blade i got some brazil nuts walnuts
pistachios
and almonds in there it's none of those
things
these aren't um cashews brazil nuts
walnuts almonds what are these
they look like walnuts pecans what are
you doing trying to act like walnuts by
the way
this food processor attachment works
with every vitamix ascent adventurous
self-detect models in a large bowl
this looks like a large bowl is this a
large bowl
this is not a large one is this a large
bowl i'm gonna combine some chopped nuts
two three four
the fact that this comes as an
attachment to this base is awesome
because
if i want to just use the blender i have
the blender just hanging out like this
and i could put this away for easy
storage do i use this to blend
sesame seeds and coconut look at that
look at that blending see i don't i'm
not used to doing this kind of motion
because i don't do this to my patients
set aside you've been cast aside
vegetable oil
packed brown sugar wow that was kind of
thick
oh man honey's so yummy to pour
not supposed to do that it's not a
sterile field oh yeah
we did that toss in the granola bars
[Music]
they didn't teach you that in culinary
school oven time
unsalted butter corn syrup
one cup of brown sugar
oh i think it's my first time using the
stove
nope yep oh i have to title the granola
bar
dr mike's girl what mike's tasty bar
bear you want some i love that this
paper says skill level moderate
master level chef here oh it's boiling
while that's cooling
oh that's okay this is harder than it
looks
i did not plan it being this hard i need
help
punch the granola punch to granola
you guys think i box to protect myself i
box
so i can granola bar god i made such a
mess
before i add the other ingredients i
want to make sure the granola is fully
granola probably should have washed my
hands before doing this now i'm stepping
on the granola
i'm getting a pedicure at the same time
cranberries
[Music]
god this is not a large enough bowl
no no how do i mix
should i use maybe a big
it's a lot easier in the pot maybe
because most of it's on the floor now
oh this is okay it's still okay
oh yes
there's definitely a technique to this
that i'm not utilizing
ah you gotta oil up your hands
well i got some massage i probably can't
use massage oil i can use this oil
though ow
granola is sharp
wow what's the purpose of oiling my
hands
[Music]
these are hands that have saved lives
and now they're pressing granola
refrigerate for two hours see if pam and
cody can get this
i'm pamela ray schuler i am a comedian
speaker and advocate
and uh dr mike's unofficial sidekick my
name is cody reese
i am a comedian i work at comedy central
sometimes in other places on the
internet and i'm also kind of like a
food dude
i make food eat food write about food
make videos about food
as a medical resident at times i needed
to have a piece of granola to keep me
going
this is so simple i'm a physician it's
never come up when you touch a food what
are you looking for
squishy factor true always the squishy
faceter at first
what does the squishy factor tell you
squishy factor it's hard to say i mean
that's the thing it's like
you i did that as a doctor i don't think
that would play off very well you when
you're touching someone's like belly and
stuff you're not like
you want me to give them a squishy how
squishy is this generally that's not
part of the chart i'm nervous about both
of these
which one do you think was good i'm not
gonna tell you what do you like in a
granola bar
energy i think he needs a magnet well
you know what if you guys really want to
know what i'm doing
i'm looking at to see like how many
different things yeah me too
and then i'm like okay did he like did
he buy a mix of like
oats that came with like weird little
sesame seeds in it i thought this was
gonna be easier and i'll tell you what
it's it's not let's go with the one you
think is mine one two
three flip em
[Music]
oh
i am slowly having more faith in your
cooking today
and pam only has half of her taste buds
is that true no
time to make a fresh green goddess it is
a salad dressing because sometimes we
want to have a healthy salad
one garlic clove peeled
fresh basil leaf
baby kale go in there baby
dandelion greens these look like
dandelion greens half a cup of
chives one whole lemon zested
and juiced i zested this myself
one teaspoon of maple syrup for that
little sugary sugary goodness
oh i didn't zest it yet i zested it now
greek yogurt full fat oh two tablespoon
extra virgin olive oil
i poured the olive oil already because i
wanted to see if you were on your toes
this is the maple syrup half a teaspoon
of salt
half of it went in half of it didn't
because we don't need too much sodium up
in this
house in the back right here this little
button says press
that's the quick release it separates
everything and makes it really easy to
pour
oh too much okay kind of want to taste
it
can i taste it
wow the product that i produce here
is identical on both plates minus the
dressing
lots of vitamins here lots of vitamins
you say lots of vitamins
are these both green goddess dressings
yes i'm gonna need you to why do you
call them green goddess well green
goddess is a classic dressing that's
like mayo based with a bunch of herbs oh
but that's not what this is i don't know
this one i like better it tastes fresher
i think i got this one
but maybe you did too are you feeling
confident or how are you feeling how do
you know you've got no i'm not confident
i think your confidence has worked
against you this far listen
my confidence has worked against me my
entire life so
flip them over wait which one the one
that one is mine
i flip them wow
i thought it was the best you could use
a little bit of salt
i'm trying to be moderate but the salt's
the key to food tasting good
that's zest in there what's this were
you like
you like get those that's the song i
made while i did
[Music]
pbnj balls peanuts salted raw almonds
oat raisins this is where the sugar
comes from six dates
i'm single now so this makes sense
let's make some balls roll in the balls
this one's too
thick look initially it looks like this
but then once my magical hands are on it
and i do this look at that ball
how do you feel about that
that's it you don't even chew it you're
sliding away buddy
these are special balls right
that i have prepared for you give us
something i cannot give you anything you
can't tell
there's a smelly ball put it in your
mouth
touch it to your forehead why don't you
tell me how you made it
with tlc do you prefer the moist or dry
i'm probably answering that easy money
let's see i'll tell you what i think
after
we flip the boards oh my god i've got
something to say
pick the store bowl ones three two one
[Music]
now flip it to yourselves
i think the one that i ate is you ate
the balls at mike mike i think it's run
it's horrible i didn't know that there
was an option that we'd be eating
horrible store box
[Music]
on to the turkey burger two turkey
breasts cut into large chunks sounded
moist
bam onion a third of a cup of mayonnaise
pop quarter cup ketchup
1 3 cup of bread crumbs 3 tablespoon of
turkey burger seasoning
mmm season it
when good burgers go bad is that the
proper consistency for a turkey burger a
pancake
bad turkey bad bad bad oh it's a good
patty oh that's juicy
[Music]
oof don't know why keeping that noise
that went upside down look at that and
then they get a little design
for the restaurant
[Music]
oh wait what do i do with
and this it on so it's evenly spread
and then press it there you go voila are
you firmly planted on thine stools
yeah i feel pretty firm i don't know how
firm i am but i feel okay about it
a burger made out of the bird known as
turkey right of course how did you know
well you can tell by the very clearly
and you may notice to your right on the
table
is a food processor attachment for the
vitamix
a 3500 blender my word that is your
prize
whoa shall you win this conference holy
moly
i want it the loser has to wash it oh
damn
i actually don't have any hands right
look at the bun this bun is like not
super fun to eat this one's probably
more fun because it's squishy and soft
i would never cut my onions or do
uncooked onions who puts uncooked onions
on something except wow you could put on
cookies
sociopaths maybe you bought this from a
really derpy place where they were put
we were cutting there
you don't know what if he's feeding us
derpy food what's a derp
oh what's a derp i like the bun on this
one better
i like the sauce on this one better this
one is more manageable where i can take
a bite of it
that sounds like a size issue i'm
keeping it classy today okay
ready the one that i think mike made one
two three
[Music]
they're both upside down hey
time to make a little basil pesto sauce
for my pasta here let's start with the
parmesan cubes
bam what you know about them pine nuts
garlic clove
bear be quiet basil olive oil
and time to put the pasta just kidding
we need it to process for one minute
and 30 seconds during which time i will
show you
my dance skills
quick release yes
look at that you spread it nice and even
and then you taste it
[Music]
i'm a chef both of these are from the
store
both of these are mine it's anybody's
game
wow they look almost identical so this
is where it's gonna get tricky folks
there's another i have to put all of the
noodles in the envelope there's no way
you have to mail them to the right
address with the post office the way it
is
today cody you have three points pam you
have four points
right for the final round you have to
wager no
ten seconds wait stop i just got the
parker start it over again
five seconds oh my god mike i will
collect these
the pastas are both from the store that
i made okay
but then the sauce so the sauce is what
we're testing use your noses use your
eyes
use your faces use your ears get a sense
of what it's telling you
it's a pesto sauce that's the green
onion obviously it's a pesto sauce
i know pam which one do you think tastes
better i don't
know which one tastes better to eat
what else can you say to me that's the
way i look at it it makes everything
much clearer
he's like taking apart the noodles i
didn't make the noodle guys no i know
you didn't make the noodle guy
i will say it is remarkably similar
they're both honestly
just okay really i don't think salt i've
never purchased pesto
not entirely sure what pesto is can
either of you tell me what kind of
pasta this is it's the squiggly boys
it's the squiggly boys there's something
in the squiggly
squiggly boys wow i thought i brought on
two food chefs
food chefs food chefs unite
i thought you dude was food chefs you're
only allowed to guess on one plate
pam you wagered how much four you
wagered
two so pam is correct she will have a
total of eight points
if she's wrong she'll have a total of
zero right if you because correctly you
will have a total of five points
if you guess incorrectly you have a
total of two points exactly i thought
this one was dr mike
and now i'm holding it up here and i
don't know
you guys are seeing something that i'm
not saying flip it if it says store then
i win
oh he got his correct and so did
uh well wait a second how many points
does that make for cody
is it five five points whatever pamela
ray schuler hold up your sign to the
audience
what do you think it is
[Music]
flip your other scoreboard wait i sticks
mine freak we should have looked at each
other's
tough well i couldn't
what happened all my pasta i think we've
all learned a lot today that's my
personal opinion i know some people
might disagree
what are you going to do with your new
vitamin 500
i'm gonna go make tortilla soup
as a happy medium can i just continue
coming here to get fed
yes that seems fair if you'd like to get
one of your own
vitamix food processor attachments and
an ascent adventurous base go on
vitamix.com
to get yours now where can we follow
your comedic and food journeys
you can follow me on uh youtube and all
other social medias um at cody reese
but be careful there's some funny stuff
on there you can follow me at pamela
comedy huge thanks to vitamix for
sponsoring this video and as always stay
happy and help and can you send me one
no clean it i want one clean it
man what does it smell like honestly
kind of like you
oh are you saying turkey
is it weird when i make eye contact with
the camera